what is a beautiful idea to you
about economics
you you mentioned a lot of them sure uh
so
as you said before there's going to be
the first view cake most people
encounter that makes the biggest
difference on average in the world
because that's the only thing most
people ever see is the first one
and so
you know with ai the first one is just
how big the problem is and but once you
get past that you'll find others
certainly for economics the first one is
just
the power of markets
um
you know you might have thought it was
just really hard to figure out how to to
optimize in a big complicated space and
markets just do a good first pass
for an awful lot of stuff and they are
really quite robust and powerful
and uh
that's just quite the view craig
where you just say you know just let up
if you if you want to get in the
ballpark just let a market handle it and
step back
and that's true for a wide range of
things it's not true for everything but
it's a it's a very good first
approximation most people's intuitions
for how they should limit markets are
actually messing them up
they're that good in sense right most
people when you go i don't know if we
want to trust that well you should be
trusting that
what about
wha
what are markets
like just a couple of words
uh so so the idea is if people want
something then let other companies form
to try to supply that thing let those
people pay for their cost of whatever
they're making and try to offer that
product to those people that many people
many such firms enter that industry and
let the customers decide which ones they
want and if the firm goes out of
business let it go bankrupt and let
other people invest in whichever
ventures they want to try to try to
attract customers to their version of
the product
and that just works for a wide range of
products and services and through all of
this there's a free exchange of
information too
there's a hope that there's no
manipulation of information and so on
that they're um you're making these even
when those things happen still just the
simple market solution is usually better
than the things you'll try to do to fix
it then the alternative
um that that's that's a view quick it's
surprising it it's you know it's not
what you would would imagine they
thought that's one of the great
i guess inventions of human civilization
right that trust the markets
now another view cake that i learned in
my research that's not all of economics
but something more specialized is
the rationality of disagreement that is
basically people who are trying to
believe what's true in a complicated
situation would not actually disagree
and of course humans disagree all the
time so it was quite the striking fact
for me to learn in grad school that
actually
rational agents would not knowingly
disagree
and so that makes disagreement more
puzzling and and it makes you less
willing to disagree
humans are to some degree rational
and are able to
their priorities
are different than just figuring out the
truth
[Laughter]
which might not be the same as being
irrational
you